[Musique]
je sors à l'instant le Che Monsieur le
Maire et moi aussi mon frère et tu m'as
passé une bague au doigts et oui ma
petite Chella c'est fini la vie de
célibataire pour moi aussi mon cher pour
toute la vie tu seras à moi moi je
n'aurai que toi alors marche marche tout
le long du chemin
ensemble la main dans la main
de
F qui sera le premier à traînmer l'autre
par le bout du
nez ta mère m'a dit que tu savais faire
qu'est-ce que je sais d'en faire tout un
tas de trucs avec tes 10 doigts j'en
suis moins sûr que toi elle a oublié de
te dire ma mère ma rabissante belleemère
que je ne sais même pas faire les US au
je les ferai donc moi alors marche
marche tout le long du CH main ensemble
la main dans la
main de
V qui sera le premier à traer l'utre par
le coup du
nez on partage tout ces FIF FIF entendu
ma chérie la voiture de sport c'est moi
qui la conduit si tu en as envie et si
tu vas voir tes copains de régiment une
fois de temps en temps tu m'en laisseras
pour passer le temps ça
al marche marche tout le long du chemin
ensemble la main dans la
main qui sera le premier à traer l're
par le
bout tous les samedis on ira chez Maman
oh comme c'est amusant et tous les étés
chez l'oncle fern oh comme c'est
excitant les petits déjeunés tu me les
serviras tu peux sur moi et tous nos
enfants c'est toi qui les fera je ne
demande que ça alors marche marche tout
le long du chemin ensemble la main dans
la
main je
t'aim si fort tu tes désirs seront des
Endres pour
[Musique]
moi